all right so i want to jump right into
this
um
horrible horrible case in
waukesha i think i'm pronouncing that
right will kesha in wisconsin
and it just so happens that um this was
a you know this this happened at a
christmas parade in wisconsin
i think uh maybe less than an hour away
from kenosha
um this was on sunday and they were
having their christmas parade and a car
an suv
drove through the middle of the parade
and
as of
the last time i checked before we
started filming
the the death toll now is five with more
than 40 people injured many of them kids
because these were kids who were in the
parade you know dancing and singing all
that kind of stuff
and this car just goes right through the
parade and keeps on driving
now let me read this from the
post-millennial and there's a lot of
information we still don't have i mean
this happened last night and there's
information coming in and so
um
of what i report right now i'm not sure
what of this will will still be relevant
by the time you listen to this but
this is from the post-millennial it says
a suspect has been identified as in
custody for the mass casualty incident
in waukesha wisconsin when a red ford
escape uh plowed into a holiday parade
so far five had been confirmed dead more
than 40 injured
according to court documents 39 year old
daryl edward brooks has been arrested as
a suspect in the incident
brooks is a career criminal with
multiple priors and was released from
jail two days prior to the incident
after posting a 1 000 bail for three
misdemeanors and two felonies
thousand dollar bail
so you've got a career criminal
multiple convictions
charged with uh with um
five
criminal counts two of them felonies
and he had a thousand dollar bill
he has a history of resisting arrest
obstruction battery statutory sexual
seduction strangulation suffocation
property destruction illegal firearm
possession bail jumping domestic
violence drug-related charges and is a
registered sex offender
and they let him out on a thousand
dollars bail
again one of his prior crimes is bail
jumping
the driver of the red suv plowed through
a police line at high speed and into a
parade of christmas marchers on sunday
impacting more than 20 adults and
children in a graphic scene captured on
the city's live stream and cell phones
of bystanders
you can
i mean i've seen some of the video of
this i don't recommend uh
watching it i mean as you can imagine
extremely disturbing
but there is there's so there are some
important details that you find when you
watch these videos and we'll get to that
in a second
now a little bit more on daryl brooks
which the post-millennial reports he's
the person of interest
um
in a rap video on his youtube page
brooks is seen dancing in front of a red
ford escape the same type of vehicle
used in sunday's fatal incident
um well kesha wisconsin police chief
daniel thompson confirmed in a press
release following the tragedy that an
officer who's been on the force for over
six years opened fire on the vehicle and
that a person of interest was in custody
uh thompson emphasized that the
investigation is quote very active
okay then we go over to
uh what
the corporate media is saying
and what we're being told so far and
again this could change
but initial reports and uh the media has
been very
very short to report this and in fact
cnn on cnn.com on their on their website
the big headline announcing this
that
as it stands right now what they're
telling us is that there was no
particular motive in this crime
that he in fact was fleeing from another
crime and that's why he drove right
through a parade
so here is the
local
nbc affiliate
it says brooks has not formally been
identified as a suspect by police and
has not been charged with a crime
the motive behind the incident remains
unclear earlier on monday a law
enforcement official said investigators
are examining whether the person of
interest in this case may have been
fleeing from a crime when he sped into
the parade goers
the investigators were questioning a
person in custody about that incident
which the official described as an
altercation involving a knife
the official who cautioned that the
investigation was still in the early
stages was continuing to develop could
not discuss the investigation so that's
um
that's what we're being told yeah the
headline on cnn says suspect in parade
tragedy may have been fleeing another
scene
okay
so a few things here
uh and we should also mention that daryl
brooks is a black man okay and that's
relevant
because it might speak to why we can't
necessarily trust what the media tells
us
all right
we know las vegas now that was a white
guy in las vegas but 50 over 50 people
were shot and killed years ago
and to this day we've never been told
why he did it
almost every other mass shooting mass
killing in recent memory um we've got a
pretty good idea of the motive they tell
us like almost right away
years later with with uh las vegas they
never told us the motive
i'm wondering
if it'll be a similar thing with
waukesha
i i wouldn't be surprised if two years
from now people are saying hey remember
that uh thing that happened when the guy
plowed through
a parade and killed a bunch of children
why did he do that whatever happened
with that
i would not be surprised if the same
thing happens here
uh because already
you know the early narrative what
they're trying to convince us is that
this was i guess basically unintentional
and that he was trying to flee the scene
of another crime
now in terms of of sentencing
it really shouldn't make a difference
because if this was intentional he was
trying to kill a bunch of people or if
this was callous disregard for human
life and he didn't care if he killed a
bunch of people either way uh it should
be really it should be a death sentence
it should be an eye for an eye sentence
where you strap him down on the road and
then a parade of cars runs over him
until he dies that's what i believe in
um now as it happens it was constant
they don't have the death penalty
anymore as far as i know but it should
still be
life in a cage never leaving ever again
regardless of the motive given how many
people died
but even so
um
was this intentional he was just trying
to flee
the scene of another crime i don't
believe that for a second
and i get very suspicious
when i hear a motive like that
proposed as a possibility
and that there's really no motive
because you can you can see the video
it is very clear in the videos that he
is intentionally targeting people
i mean the car turns so that he hits
more people
now if you're fleeing the scene of a
crime you're just trying to get away and
let's say you don't really care that
much if you hit people but you your main
motivation is you wanna you wanna get
away from uh from from the cops
well for one thing you'd probably go
around the parade
just for the sake of going faster you go
around but also you would start honking
your horn you would try to steer around
people again if even if you don't care
about their lives it's going to let you
go faster if you don't hit anybody so it
just doesn't make it easy he never honks
his horn never announces that he's
coming
makes no attempt to go around anybody
he goes through multiple intersections
and never turns
and yet we're being told that
potentially he was just fleeing the
scene of another crime i don't believe
it
i don't buy it
now what we know is that this person of
interest is a black man and um
there are indications
there are reports
that he was at a minimum a blm supporter
and he appears to have rap videos where
he's got a lot of anti-white rhetoric
and that sort of thing
so you have to wonder
did that have anything to do with this
was he at all motivated i mean is it a
coincidence that this happened
only a few miles away from kenosha
a couple of days after the verdict
is it just a coincidence that the
verdict happens and then may and then
apparently a blm supporter plows through
a um a parade of mostly white people is
it could be
it could be
but um
i don't believe the initial narrative
i'll just tell you that i personally
don't believe it it doesn't make any
sense it does not pass the common sense
smell test
and the problem is
now let's just say that there is some
element of
and it could be a combination of these
things i mean it could be he's fleeing
the scene of a crime he figures his life
is over anyway sees a crime of
opportunity here might as well take out
some people you know
so there could be a combination of that
kind of motive who i don't know
but um
the problem is that let's just say
theoretically hypothetically
that there is at least some element of
motive here
and that he was targeting these people
as he really appears to be doing in the
video
and that he was um
he was
spurred on in that direction by a lot of
the misreporting and the false
narratives in the media
well if that were the case then we'd be
relying on the media to tell us
that it's their fault partly that this
happened
i don't trust the media to tell me that
so we're in a position with this uh with
this case that
hey we we're probably gonna be las vegas
we're never gonna know the truth
because whatever the media tells me
about this i i can't believe it i don't
trust it i do not trust what you're
telling me corporate media
if if if the reality of this case
is extremely inconvenient for you and
your narrative i don't believe that you
will tell me
and then when they're insulting our
intelligence early on by saying that
potentially he was just fleeing the
scene of a crime give me a break
and of course we know that you know
reverse the race is here
if this was a white man plowing through
a parade of mostly black people um
the corporate media
immediately within like a second along
with every elected democrat they would
be saying this is racially motivated
this is a hate crime that's what they'd
be saying
i'm not even saying that because i i
don't know
what i'm saying is that to me seems like
at least a possibility
and the story they're telling us early
on doesn't make sense to me and i don't
believe it
um there's another aspect of this case
that we do that that appears to be
pretty well established
that this man if he in fact was the
guilty party um
career criminal out on bail
and so this is what this is what bail
reform
and justice reform gets us
whether or not false media narratives
are partly to blame i suspect they might
be
but we certainly know that bail reform
justice reform
shares some of the blame here
because this man never should have been
out of prison in the first place
okay there has to be a point
where we as as a society can say
um and this is what three strikes
strike laws were supposed to be about
there has to be a point where we as a
society can say to someone okay
you've made it clear to us that you have
no interest
in living in society as a civilized
human being you've made it clear to us
that you want to be
that you want to act like an animal
and so
that's how you're going to be treated
we're going to put you in a cage for the
rest of your miserable life there has to
be a point where we can say that as as a
society the idea that we we keep cycling
these people through the system and
putting them back on the street until
they do something so heinous
that that even the most progressive da
would have to go for a life and sentence
uh a life in in prison sentence you know
that
system that strategy
doesn't work
it results directly in these sorts of
things
because whether they say it or not that
is you know that's that's the strategy
that these progressive das many of them
um put in their position partly through
funding from george soros and other
um
other uh you know wealthy activists
but whether they say it explicitly or
not
that's their strategy that's their
philosophy that they're going to keep
putting people back on the street keep
putting them back on the street back on
the street and until they do something
until they at least kill someone and
even then we they still might end up
back on the street
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated